القاهره وانقره تعليقان على مصافحه السيسي
واردوغان كشف سبب اخفاء موردين فريدوم
فريمنده في افتتاح كاس العالم وتسجيله
اطول وقت بدل ضائع في الشوط الاول بتاريخ
المونديال هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تعليقا على المصافحه التي شهدتها الدوحه
بين الرئيسين المصري والتركي قبيله افتتاح
بطوله كاس العالم اكد بيانو للرئاسه
المصريه على عمق العلاقه بين البلدين
الناطق باسم الرئاسه المصريه اوضحها انه
تم التوافق على ان يكون اللقاء بين
الرئيسين بدايه لتطوير العلاقات الثنائيه
في مقاله اردوغان ان تلك المصافحه كانت
خطوه اولى نحو مزيد من التطبيعه في
العلاقات بين البلدين مشيرا الى ان طلب
بلاده الوحيد من مصر هو تغيير اسلوبها
تجاه الوضع التركي في البحر المتوسط
بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين موسكو وكاف حول
قصر محطه النوويه جنوب اوكرانيا حضرت
روسيا من مخاطر وقوع حادث النووي في
المكان النطق باسم الكرام قال في تصريحات
انه يشعر بالقلق من تجدد القصف على محطه
زخريجيا مطلع الاسبوع الجاري في معتبر
مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رافاييل جروسي ان القصف كان متعمدا ومحدد
الهدف وصفا الوضع بالخطير للغايه دون ان
يحمل القوات الروسيه او الاوكرانيه
المسؤوليه
وفي اخبار المونديال شهد الشوط الاول من
المباراه التي جمعت بين منتخب بين انجلترا
وايران في افتتاح مباريات المجموعه
الثانيه في بطوله كاس العالم اطول وقت
اضافيه الشوط الاول في التاريخ المسابقه
حكم اللقاء البرازيلي رفايل كلاوس احتسب
اربعه عشر دقيقه كم وقت بدل ضائع للشوط
الاول بسبب تعرض حارس المرمى الايراني
لاصابه بانفه بعد نحو عشر دقائق فقط من
بدايه المباراه التي انتهت بفوز ساحق
للانجليز لنتيجه سته اهداف مقابل اهدافين
لايران
اثار الممثل الامريكي موجين فريمان فضول
كثيرين على السوشيال ميديا بتعامده اخفاء
يده اليسرى بقفاز اثناء افتتاح كاس العالم
في قطر 20 22 تقارير افادت بان النجمه
الهوليوديه الشهير كشف في حوار اعلامي قبل
سنوات ان السبب ارتدائه القفاز يعود لحادث
اليم تعرض له في يدها افقدها القدره على
الحركه وقال فريمان وقتها ان السبب هو ان
يده تنتفخ بسبب قله الحركه وتجمع الدماء
بها ما يستدعي ارتداء قفاز طبي لتحريك
الدوره الدمويه بها باستمرار ولذا يرتديه
منذ 2008
في خبر ان الاخير قال دونالد ترامب انه لا
يرى اي سبب للعوده الى منصه تويتر بعد
اعلان المالك الجديد للشركه ايلون ماسك
رفع الحظر عن الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب اوضح في تصريحات ان تويتر لديه
الكثير من المشاكل مشيرا الى ان المنصه
تعرف انتشارا للروبوتات والحسابات المزيفه
وان المشكلات التي تواجهها تويتر لا تصدق
كان حساب ترامب قد تم حظره من تويتر بسبب
اتهامه بالتحريض على العنف خلال هجوم
انصاره في السادس من يناير على مبنى
الكابتن
[موسيقى]